I didn't get to the psychic one last
time again what am I giving you things
I'm literally giving you just a skeleton
of a proof I hesitate to call it a proof
really I haven't given you all like the
rigorous labeling and reasons and
what-have-you but I am showing you like
okay what's the general direction and
often what's the insight that you need
in order to make the proof just kind of
collapse so psychic quad the most
important thing about a psychic quad is
that its opposite angles are
supplementary just a quick note on the
word supplementary just like the word
this is more of a language thing than
anything else just like the word
complimentary each one implies that
there are two objects right you've got
one thing and it's supplement well you
have another bit and it's complement so
when you talk about supplementary angles
or complementary angles you're always
talking about a pair alright so you know
3150 2160 and so on right so it isn't
really right to say for instance some
angles on a straight line ah
supplementary question mode because you
might have lots of lots of angles on
there that's really not that big a deal
like we know what you mean that adds up
to 180 but if that's what you mean why
don't you just say that saying
anything's on a straight line out of 180
so this idea of supplementary
complementary really is about pairing
and that's exactly what we have
everything okay so for what something
every here in 180 minus something over
there how would you go about doing this
often in circle geometry it's all about
you know adding stuff onto the diagram
adding constructions that make things
clearer so here's what I'm gonna do -
lions the diagonal
now once you have your diagonals on
there you have a whole bunch of again
pairs of angles that are equal to each
other loads and loads and loads you just
have to go to see them right so for
example let's pull up our Greek alphabet
here if I look at this angle I'm going
to call it alpha there's another angle
in this diagram which is also alpha
right this angle here is forged by these
two intervals into court so it's
standing on this earth down the bottom
do you see that so being that steady or
that arc any other angle standing on the
same arc which is also discover it's
full so the Alpha so do you see it it's
up in the top right isn't it there's
alpha got it okay now once you see that
that's alpha now that doesn't get you
very far
but there's loads of other pairs that
are exactly the same for example if you
look at the diagram upside down and you
see okay there's another arc up here
it's top which of subtends two angles at
the bottom right do you see them so for
example I could call them gonna be there
I can call them beat up and beat up
right okay now business is a cyclic
quadrilateral it's made of four chords
which means it divides off it separates
out four arcs of the circle so therefore
you have four pairs I can keep on doing
this where are the others let's see I've
got gamma yeah Bob over there see those
guys and then lastly I don't think I
have a fourth color with me
unfortunately but I've got Delta Delta
okay you see what I've done now this
trick now it's almost identical to
proven that the angle in a semicircle is
90 degrees what would be the line that
you write down having made all these
constructions and labels yeah Doris
great my eight angles add up to 360
degrees because they are the angles on
the record you lateral so what I really
have is 2 alpha plus 2 beta plus 2 gamma
plus 2 Delta equals
a full revolution and all you need to do
just like with the angle in the
semicircle is divide the whole thing
hard at all which gives you this but you
can see right alpha alpha plus beta
turns out for a beta for this gamma plus
Delta then the opposite angle is if I
just rearranged a little bit okay there
you go there's this angle over here and
there is this over here right so that's
it they're supplementary I've a menorah
okay of course it only takes a really
quick steps to know the other important
thing you - like a calculator which is
if you add the external angle over here
and exterior angle I should say because
these two angles now add up to two these
add up to 180 as well yeah you see that
so if these two add up to infinity and
these two add up to 180
and this guy over here must be exactly
the same as that one over there it has
to be alpha plus gamma right to get the
four different angles to be hundred
eighty degrees so the exterior angle of
a cyclic quadrilateral is equal to the
opposite interior angle you have to say
the opposite one because not just any of
them it's really not one think